happy holidays to everyone one and all
it's it's me pete holmes as you can tell
it's the holidays and that means it's
time for me to answer some of your
holiday questions in a segment we call
ask pete holiday questions
roger ash wants to know what is eggnog
roger great question uh eggnog is a
holiday excuse to drink brandy a liquor
known to get you drunk enough to make
love to somebody that before you had the
brandy you thought looked pretty gross
in their holiday sweater but then before
you know it you're hanging the mistletoe
on your belt buckle and going ho ho ho
if you know what i mean then you're on
the bed and you're sloshing and there's
this weird egg yolk sugar drink mushing
around in your bellies you can't see it
but it's
and that's how babies are born
travis baker says if santa be fake then
how them cookies get eat well i put my
answer into google translate just so i
could speak to travis in the way that he
spoke to me
well travis that'd be great question
fake ass santa not really be visit every
house on christmas eve but reindeers do
be skimming them clouds storming them
chimneys
eating them cookies
paul kraft has a fun question he says
how do you give proper credit to gifts
that are less than great i've never had
a good poker face am i just
no paul you're not just it's the
holidays here's a way to get around that
if you think a gift might be something
you don't like pick it up and before you
open it pretend it is something you like
just scream oh my god a vintage sega
genesis oh my god a vintage sega genesis
and run around and run around and run
around then when you open it either one
of two things will happen it is a
vintage sega genesis
awesome or it's not and everybody's too
freaked out to talk to you
thomas morrison wants to know who would
win in an arm wrestling competition
santa claus or jesus
uh who could win
jesus who would win santa why because
jesus cool like that
and finally justin wong says what's the
point of that channel that only plays
the clip of the burning yule log on loop
and do you get as excited as i do
whenever that hand comes out to poke it
well justin i'll tell you a little
something about show business in
hollywood because i'm in show business
and live in hollywood
ratings baby
and it's a tale as old as time that you
can't beat a burning eulog that's
occasionally poked by a hand
you can't it's like dancing with the
stars america's sexiest person
and pornography looped into one majestic
burning log in fact if we had a yule log
on our show i'm sure our ratings would
oh my god